etienne blanc pour le groupe l'est
républicain merci merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le garde des sceaux que ce
garde des sceaux depuis quelques
semaines nous assistons en france dans
les cours d'appel et dans les tribunaux
de grande instance à des mouvements de
grève et à des mouvements de
contestation qui sont profonds ils ont
pour cause de manque de moyens de nos
juridictions et on constate des postes
qui ne sont pas pourvus au siège comme
au parquet
on constate des délais trop longs pour
le paiement des frais d'expertisé et
d'ailleurs ces retards ou ses
manquements
vous les avez vous même pointé dans le
rapport annuel de performance qui a été
communiqué à la commission des finances
nous avons constaté une dégradation très
sensible et des indicateurs dans ce
rapport de performance par exemple et
les délais d'audiencement augmente ça
retarde les procédures
par exemple les délais de jugement
augmente ça retarde l'issue de ces
procédures mais on peut aussi constater
de des difficultés très importantes dans
les délais et dans lé rythme d'exécution
des peines comment l'expliquer on
l'expliqué évidemment par un écart
considérable entre les annonces qui sont
faites dans la loi de finances initiale
et les résultats que l'on constate en
fin d'année par exemple monsieur le
garde des sceaux en 2015 nous avons 45
magistrat de moins que nous n'en avions
en 2012 en 2015
nous avons autant de greffiers nous en
avions en 2009 et le rythme
d'augmentation des postes dans le
domaine de la pénitentiaire
c'est quasiment tahri on peut dire aussi
qu'il y à 22 % de diminution de nos
investissements
alors monsieur le garde des sceaux ma
question est simple comment
imaginez-vous en un an
honoré l'engagement du président de la
république c'était l'engagement 52 et 53
qui consistait à donner des moyens
importants à la justice pour la
moderniser et en faire une institution
solide au service de la république
comment allez vous monsieur le garde des
sceaux comment allez vous rattraper en
un an ce qui n'a pas été fait en garde
si monsieur la parole et à monsieur le
garde des flots mise de la justice
monsieur jean jacques urvoas
oui monsieur le président chers etienne
blanc je crois comprendre que d'une
certaine façon c'est votre dernière
intervention dans l'hémicycle
puisque vous avez annoncé votre
démission et donc vous allez quitter ses
bancs donc je veux saluer le travail que
vous avez fait depuis 2002 et notamment
dans le cadre du budget sur la justice
que vous connaissez bien puisque vous
êtes rapporteur du budget mais vous
posez des questions monsieur le député
auquel vous avez les réponses
bien sûr qu'il ya moins de magistrats
aujourd'hui qu'il y en avait en 2012
mais parce que la majorité à laquelle
vous appartenez on a supprimé
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est vous qui
le dites dans vos rapports tous les ans
tous les ans vous avez supprimés entre
2007 et 2012
monsieur le député c'est dans votre
rapport que j'ai consultés il y a dix
minutes
cent quatre magistrats ont été supprimés
alors moi j'ai pas pour habitude de
repousser sur les autres la
responsabilité vous dire ce que nous
faisons ce que nous faisons ce que nous
faisons depuis 2012 monsieur le député
vous le savez fort bien parce que vous
l'avez noté dans votre rapport
budgétaire
nous avons créé 1582 poste de magistrat
1582 poste dans la promotion qui sera
l'école nationale de la magistrature
il y aura 3 173 magistrats en 2016 je
crois savoir qu'il ya un dirigeant de
l'opposition qui propose qu'il y ait
encore demain moins de fonctionnaires
et bien pas dans cette majorité monsieur
le député dans la justice nous sommes
prioritaires
vous parlez des greffiers nous avons
créé 700 postes de greffiers en trois
ans vous parlez des surveillants de
prison et bien je vous invite à venir
avec moi dans quelques jours fin avril à
l'école nationale de l'administration
pénitentiaire à agen pour saluer la
promotion de surveillants de prison ils
sont 868 voilà ce que nous allons faire
monsieur le député réparer ce que vous
avez un peu abîmée merci monsieur le
ministre
par là même